what's your issue with
codling I think
um there's there's a few different
things and they're all sort of um
they're all part of the same sort of
sticky web of dysfunction um so there's
codling there's social media there's
therapy
culture um the sort of pop psychology
stuff that I that I criticize a lot and
they're all they're all very related so
codling you could almost look at codling
as safety culture for children and which
of course children need safety but over
protecting children and um too much
safety it seems to stunt development it
seems to stunt your ability to overcome
obstacles to mitigate your emotions your
aggression your impulses um to to have
any sort of resilience um when you know
to the vicissitudes of Life which no
one's no one's immune to um and then and
and the sort of extension of childhood
that coddled that coddled childhood
which is now extended you
know it used to be that you you were an
adult around 15 or or 16 um or 18 and
now it seems to go on and on much you
know into into the early 20s if not
further you have 30-year-olds saying I'm
adulting um if you're an adult it's just
Behavior it's not adulting um and then I
guess safety culture which is which is
like codling for adults it's it's like
treating adults like infants um
incapable infants who who couldn't cope
with a different opinion and if they you
know have The Misfortune of of coming
into contact with an opinion that makes
them uncomfortable then they need a safe
space with puppies and coloring books
yeah what what are the ways that this
safety culture codling culture for
adults how does that manifest what are
the behaviors that we
see so you you I mean you would see it
everywhere so You' see you see it
probably the most obvious um examples I
think come from University campuses so
you see when anybody who's not um
completely dialed into the sort of
American flavor of you know social
justice leftism when they're um invited
onto college campuses to have a talk the
huge hu in in North America the huge
demonstrations that break out um people
accuse them of personally victimizing
them um there's you know sometimes they
people are scared for their safety
they're worried they're going to get
attacked um safe spaces are often
provided there's trigger warnings um you
know within acade within your actual
academic work there's trigger warnings
and the research shows that trigger
warnings don't actually work they make
things worse because then there's that
anticipatory anxiety about um oh I'm
going to get triggered um
there's you see it in in this pop
psychology stuff where um everybody's
traumatized and um we can't say anything
that might hurt anyone's feelings ever
um you know the greatest crime anybody
can the greatest sin is causing offense
um so they're all they're all quite
closely linked I'd say but this this to
me sounds a lot like the concern over um
over protectionism strategies especially
on college campuses especially in
liberal arts colleges and stuff around
America and maybe creeping into the UK
as well but what does this have to do
with adult mental health like how is
this not just a culture War topic like
because you have expertise you're a a
practicing
psychotherapist yeah um who also knows a
bit of like psychoanalysis he stuff too
that's kind of more my area um I'm sort
of I would say psychodynamic or
psychoanalytic
psychotherapist um everyone knows what
that
is it's it's the form of therapy that's
derivative of what people think of when
they think of you know Freud um but it's
um an upd updated modern version of it
and the you know sort of basic premise
of this form of therapy um is that the
mind is divided against itself so
there's there's all these different
forms of um all these different
conflicts or different parts of us that
want different things have different
needs um and so we're constantly working
across purposes with ourselves and that
often happens
unconsciously um it looks at how the
past is alive in the here and now and
then you know like a good example would
be like the DSM thinking is that any any
mental health issue is a disease um sort
of akin to akin to the way we think of
um physiological diseases and in
psychoanalytic and of course there are
there are very you know mental illness
is very real um but in psychoanalytic
thinking you would see something like
depression or anxiety as
um a sort of sort of a like a fever or
like a symptom that's telling you
there's an underlying infection that's
causing this symp
so you'd of course have you know your
patient or client um see a psychiatrist
or get whatever they need but at the
same time you would work on addressing
the underlying underlying
infection yeah I had uh Jonathan shedler
on the show a little while ago and he
yeah he's he was phenomenal and that was
the first time that I really started to
see a bit of the psychoanalytical
psychodynamic stuff I'm still largely
I'm like an EP boy through and through
like I know my Evolution and then all
the rest of this stuff is like again
outside of my area of expertise but yeah
so again just round this out for me you
are mental health expert work with
clients oneon-one sort of very well
qualified but draw this line between
what kind of sounds a little bit like
what Ben Shapiro might talk about a lot
and mental health like how do your
expertise give you a an Insight or what
is happening in these environments
that's impacting your world and the
people that enter your world okay well
first I just want to say I don't I don't
see myself as an expert because I'm I'm
barely a about a decade into my career
and in in the people all the people I
admire um have had like 40 years under
their belts and and they're [__]
amazing but anyway um the the line I
would draw is
that when you when you prevent children
and it's not always because you know
parents are doing the wrong thing it's
also the the environment M wherein um
everything's on screens you know
children younger and younger are getting
on social media um there's a level of
disconnection there's far less Rough and
Tumble play which children need to
develop it's you know play isn't um
isn't a fun treat it's actually a
developmental necessity um and when you
look at the codling and the
overprotection you think of sort of like
colloquially you might call it a
helicopter parent so parents always
hovering hovering around and
um far too closely so you don't give the
child one the space to actually develop
um and they they're often removing
obstacles from a child's path obstacles
they need um so if you prevent a child
from experiencing anything difficult you
stop any form of conflict or difficulty
with other children um you don't give
them age appropriate responsibility
you're essentially stunting their their
ability to have those skills as an adult
um and you're also stunting their
ability
to to learn how to um how to go through
something difficult and and and manage
your emotions around it you know we see
these like vast groups of adults that
that just can't they just can't manage
their emotions when something difficult
comes up like they can't take their
punches standing up every single time
flattened
um and you know that would be that would
be the line so Jonathan hate who has you
know done some incredible work in his
his Incredible Book the example he
always gives is of the immune system um
and which which ties into um Nasim
talib's you know um idea of
antifragility and the immune system for
us to develop immunity we have to come
into contact with pathogens we have to
come come into contact with things that
threaten the immune system and stress it
out and it's only by coming into contact
with those difficult things that the
immune system sort of learns to um fight
themel do you see that uh children who
live in a household that's got a
dishwasher have doubled the rates of uh
asthma and children who live in
households that have a dog have half the
rates of asthma so you fall that makes
perfect sense because the the um the N
peanut allergies the rate of peanut
allergies is also skyrocketed you know
this um because there's you know again
the safety culture there's so much
protectiveness um about some child in
this class might have a peanut allergy
so there's nothing no nuts
allowed we have almost a
um there's a mirror scenario going on
here between what happens biologically
in terms of the immune system and what
happens psychologically in terms of our
ability to be robust absolutely what do
you think you know victimhood victimhood
culture being a victim again very
popular term that's been thrown around a
lot what do you think most of the
conversations around victimhood
Miss like most things on social media
everything turns into a very reductive
binary so you have one side that is
wallowing in victimhood and it's you
know um just ludicrous things and you
and you just think good god get a life
like you this shouldn't flatten you
um and and you know collecting I I call
it wound collecting you know all these
different things that that add to their
you know victimhood Matrix that means
they're more special or more important
somehow and then on the other side you
have people that seem to have absolutely
no basic human empathy and um you know
just sort of Shame and castigate anybody
who's who might be having a hard time or
been through difficult things and I
think the the the Nuance that gets lost
is that there's a big difference between
actually having been
victimized and identifying as a victim
and what I'm criticizing is always the
latter so there are people who've been
who've been victimized and in my
anecdotal experience and in my clinical
experience I find that people who've
really been through horrible horrific
things often do not want to themselves
as a victim because that that adds to
you know the retraumatization feelings
of having the agency taken away from
them they're often people who had no
choice but to to find the resources to
survive who are still suffering the
impacts of what they went through and
it's more the people
who have you know a certain degree of
anxiety and neuroticism and um low mood
and you know great difficulty Reg ating
their affect or their emotions that
identify as that really sort of um hone
in on this on this victimhood stuff
because it gives them a really helpful
convenient framework that explains
what's going on for them while also
giving you social currency and
um and you're much less likely to to be
demonized and attacked if you're a
victim yeah what what's the difference
between pain and Trauma
pain is but pain is just a a reality of
life we all have pain every single one
of us has has has pain that's just you
know The Human Condition trauma is um
well the word trauma as well it's it's
it's so flat and is difficult to to
sometimes pass it out
but traumatic exposure is going through
something that like like having lived
through war or being um phys physically
abused or sexually assaulted um you know
any any of those sorts of things that
completely overloads Your Capacity to
cope to the point that you might not
even be able to form memories of what
happened to you um or what you went
through and then it it leaves an injury
and it's an injury that's that's
neurobiological so um it actually
changes the structure of the brain it
changes um and you know it's also
psychological injury
um and people have symptoms like you
know the stereotypical things that you
see in films which is flashbacks and um
um you know reliving the the what you
went through and Nightmares but also
things like um insomnia and intrusive
thoughts and pervasive overwhelming
feelings of shame or that you're a bad
person um complete damage to your
capacity to attach to other people
because your trust has been so badly
broken it's it's one of those things
that's so alive in your every day that
it's almost as though you're always
responding to the traumatic thing you
went through and there's also difference
between going through something like
that something traumatic and developing
PTSD because not everybody goes through
something traumatic and develops PTSD
and um the the protective factors there
seem to be meaningful relationships and
support um if you have that before
during and after it can it can help
mitigate um the impacts of of of the
traumatic experience um and and then
people who do develop it often don't
have don't have support and also
sometimes have a have a history of some
form of abuse or mental health
difficulties or yeah and temperament
individual temperament one of the quotes
from you that I love is being impacted
by what happened to you isn't victimhood
it's human making an identity out of it
is victimhood yeah yeah and it's that
sort of uh degree of attachment right
this uh sort of romanticization of
pathologization that's such a good way
to put it yeah
um
there's when you have been
victimized you might make an identity
out of victimhood or you might always
feel like a victim and that's not the
same again as what I'm what I'm
criticizing but it's something you have
to work on you you really do because
when your agency's taken away um and
when I say your agency is taken away
what I mean is that something is done to
you against your will and you and and
there was nothing you could do to
prevent it it's an incredibly powerless
paralyzing feeling um and again you know
it's part of the injury that's left on
you especially if it happens in early
life
so anything that happens to us when
we're developing you know forms the
fabric of of who we are so you might
then go on to always feel as though you
don't have agency because you never
you've never felt that you did you might
you might you know it's something that
you've never really um even occurred to
you that you could you could tap into or
use um and you might live in the
world as somebody who has no agency who
things just happen to um and it's
directly related to having your agency
previously taken away so again those
people need help they need help
integrating what happened to them
forming a cohesive narrative around it
um and and learning how to how to take
that
agency back or or learning how to tap
into it um and then the other
group and it really frustrates me
because it's like you're making a
mountain for yourself when you you
needn't if if you knew what people
suffer when what a living nightmare it
is to actually live with the after
effects of being traumatized you
wouldn't want to claim that for yourself
trust me you wouldn't survive a day of
it um so you
know beating the drum of I'm So
victimized I'm so offended um I deserve
special treatment I have no agency so
everybody has to do things for me um
that that would be the difference
between the two groups I'd say
yeah it's it's interesting I I kind of
made an analogous
analogous
uh point between these Tik toks of girls
that had said this guy glanced over
three times in 90 seconds while I was
videoing myself doing glute bridges in a
gym therefore this is toxic male gays
and it's the patriarchy and you should
be worried because men are predators
what that does if it's responded to
positively and if the internet says yes
you were in the right what happens is
many other girls use that as their new
bar for what is and is not acceptable
behavior from men and the bar continues
to just move lower and lower and lower
right that what would have previously
been innocuous is now uh something that
should warrant anxiety inside of
yourself it's almost like the concept
creep of interpersonal interactions
right that it continues to just get more
and more and more sensitive I think uh
employees at Netflix are only allowed to
stare at the opposite sex for no more
than 5 Seconds there was um uh posters
on the London Underground uh telling men
that they weren't supposed to look at
women for more than a particular amount
of time the toxic male gays again um but
going back to something you mentioned
earlier on you spoke about uh people
might struggle uh attaching they might
have intrusive thoughts they might be
down and depressed and blah blah blah
like everyone has that right everybody
has that and there is a there is a a
spectrum upon which everyone exists from
having absolutely none of it and there's
one out of 100 maybe that's there and
having it all the time and there's maybe
one out of 100 that's there and then
there's this sort of lovely lovely
little bell curve in the middle of that
and this is again something else I
learned from you the difference between
the worried well and people with genuine
mental illness and again it's this
romanticization of pathologization or
the sort of weaponization of feelings in
a way because the victim is what's being
pedestalize there is uh a type of
odd type of status that comes from being
at the bottom of the pile in some way
even if you're only at the bottom of the
pile because you've identified that you
are and you know it's the people who
have been through absolute hell that
seem to be the most robust and there's a
paradox that the ones that are the most
privileged are the people who are the
most fragile but my point being that
because everybody has this everyone has
a degree of legitimacy to claiming well
I am that you know I do have intrusive
thoughts I do get down and S I do have
all the rest of it also our inner
experience is completely opaque to
everybody else so God knows exactly
what's going on here but yeah the the
this
desire this desire from people who don't
have a you know a real mental illness
issue to use the label because it gives
them some sort of um Power and I don't
think it's all to do with this uh
desired overreach for status by being a
victim I think a good chunk of it as
well is by pathologizing whatever the
problem is it gives you a sense of
control over what's happening right that
it's not just wow the world is random
and and sometimes I end up on the
receiving end of of [__] it's oh no
this is because of a a it's got a name
to it right that helps me to kind of box
it into a particular type of of issue
and and it gives me some sense of order
right outside of the chaos um but yeah
this the difference between people who
are genuinely mentally ill or have are
struggling with with issues uh and then
yeah this uh this other concern this the
worried well as you call them um well
the thing about Netflix is hilarious and
what a it sounds like it sounds like
something between like a cross between
an SNL sketch uh sketch and like the
handmaid's tail it just sounds so stupid
like you can only look at people for
five seconds what happens if you look at
someone for six you get fired not good
not good there's an alarm is there a
quota you have to look for five like if
you look at four for only four it's rude
um and it reminds me of of when Jordan
Peterson was writing his second book and
I can't remember which the who the
publisher was um and they announced it
and all the employees started crying
penguin random
house and you just it's it's yeah it's
just it's ridiculous um that is it's
ridiculous and the same with London
transport does it does it work the other
way or women also only allowed to look
at men for 5 seconds or whatever it is
um I'm I'm sure it I think that there
would be a campaign for men for women to
look at them for longer you can only
look at me for a minimum of 10 seconds
but long longer if you can um but yeah
this is you know this really seems to be
the worried well and the genuinely the
genuinely traumatized or genuinely sort
of mentally uh upset they seem to be the
you know the two one group is laughing
as the other wishing that they could be
and this group is looking at that one
going why would you wish any of the
things that currently struggling with I
wish that I could get rid of them yeah
or they just go very quiet um I've
received a look because because I I make
a fair amount of posts
distinguishing um actual Trauma from
social media trauma and every time I do
I get this delu of emails from people
with actual PTSD who say thank you for
saying that um I don't talk about you
know what I've been through anymore
because I I live with this that and the
other it's like it's like having a
disability and my friend who just had a
breakup is saying that we we're
suffering from the same thing so I just
don't talk about it anymore
um the worried well I mean really that's
just another way of of sort of
neuroticism I guess which is being um
susceptible to negative feelings and um
and I think the level of of information
online that's shared under the guise of
psychoeduc ation really doesn't help
because it's completely decontextualized
knowledge you know like in the UK
therapists psychotherapists are not
allowed to diagnose you have to do quite
a lot of additional training and you
have to be a clinical psychologist or a
psychiatrist and it takes time to learn
you know how to um how to discern what
what something is um it's not there
aren't necessarily the same kind of
bright lines in uh you know
Psychopathology that there are in with
physical
illnesses and you know like you said
think everything will it's called
medical students disease so when you're
training to be a doctor or therapist or
something you everything you read you
think oh my God I must have this and
it's um and and we're just doing that to
everybody we're just doing just
unleashing that on the public the
difference is that you continue your
training and then you understand you
understand why it all resonates
understand that no I don't I don't have
every single you know um diagnosis in
the DSM but the lay you know public
don't don't have that they they just get
the five signs you have anxiety or six
signs that you've got OCD and it's all
human behavior like you said so things
will resonate with you but there's also
a difference you know
like what one person might call an
intrusive thought might be oh just a
random thought popped into my head
what's somebody with OCD or or PTSD
might might well what they what is an
intrusive thought for them is suddenly I
had this awful flash that I'm going to
you know this image in my head of
stabbing my mother and I and I'm really
scared I'm going to lose control and do
it um yeah I suppose the the fact that
you need to communicate this and
especially when it's done online on
Instagram captions or whatever that it's
done in a manner that is still largely
open to interpretation and maybe is even
designed
to be done so kind of the same way that
a medium or an astrology card is
purposefully vague and uses language
that's so woolly that it could be
interpreted by anyone like the astrology
of psychology that we've got going on
here where yeah you allow it to be
interpreted how oh that's me this post
this post is so me or this post is my
spirit animal right like that that
feeling of being seen you can't say
spirit animal that's highly
problematic why is spirit animal
problematic I believe it it's um
problematic because you are culturally
appropriating a Native American idea I
see so nothing can be a cism anymore if
the Native Americans come for me I I I
will I will apologize appropriately
after they've chopped scalped me and
chopped my head off
um yeah this this uh almost purposefully
Wally language and and there is you know
again I don't want it to seem like
anybody that's going through I've been
through mental health struggles myself
throughout all of my 20s like I I really
really want people to understand that
there is a conversation understand that
there is there are resources and there
is help and all the rest of the things
that you can do so I don't want it to be
like us lambasting it
but the main reason is that people feel
like their emotions are a personal curse
on them right I would I'm never no
matter how good friends me and you
become I'm never going to know the
texture of your own mind I'm never going
to know what it feels like to be Ser
right I'm not going to
know when you say Sad do you mean what I
mean when I say sad when you say that
you couldn't sleep because you had you
you were overthinking last night do you
are you overthinking at the same sort of
pace that I am or just how visceral is
the emotion are you sweating am I do you
know what I mean and this desire for us
to feel seen right in a world that's
very atomized and individualized where
the self is upheld more highly than
everything else and we're obsessed with
our own
emotions in this world someone that
posts something that makes us feel like
we're not that this isn't some
individual uh like custom drug that's
being pumped into our veins to make us
suffer oh it's just a part of The Human
Experience that's me so that I
understand the compulsion to pathologize
and put a label on the things that we're
feeling because it makes us
feel less
objectified by our own emotions less of
a less of a victim of our own of our own
issues it's oh just just it's just you
know it's what it's every look at 20,000
likes on this Instagram post like all of
those people are
too it some of those some of those
accounts are very clever about how they
do it and they put things in a way that
will resonate or will cost the wi widest
net possible because um it pro it it
benefits them um
there's there's a couple of things there
so one absolutely when if you're
struggling with something and you find
out um that that you know this is this
is something other people from suff
suffer from too there's a name for it it
changes your relationship with the thing
that you're suffering from so imagine
for example having the symptoms of
anxiety and your heart races and you've
always got you know butterflies in your
tummy and and your hands have a Tremor
and you're always worried and you know
some of those feelings and you don't
know what it is and you don't know if
anybody else feels that way I think it
would be absolutely horrific um and then
you find out something called anxiety
and then you find out you know why does
anxiety form what's the evolutionary
purpose of of of having feelings like
anxiety and it it can change your
relationship to it it can um change the
way you regulate and and manage and
respond to those feelings of
anxiety um and I guess the other side of
the coin is taking every normal
little human emotion and attempting to
um attempting
to I guess label it and and pathologize
it so you know some of the the
definitions of trauma on um online or in
amongst insta therapy they're ridiculous
it's it's basically just they'll
describe the Human Experience and say
this is trauma um you know do you ever
do you ever breathe have you ever seen
the color blue you have trauma um so
it's sort
of I think what you said was was really
insightful because it's true you we
don't like uncertainty we don't like
feeling um we're not very good at
tolerating uncertainty or feeling that
we don't have control over something and
so if you combine that
um you know H having this emotional
experience that that is quite difficult
and turbulent and you don't have you
know a lot of control over it you don't
know if it's ever going to end you
you're not good at managing it with
having been coddled and protected to the
point that you don't have the skills to
cope or manage and probably led to some
of those feelings that you're feeling
and then you add to it this pop
psychology culture that's telling you oh
this is a legitimate diagnosis and
nobody should ever make you
uncomfortable and no one should ever you
know um criticize you or suggest that
you have to take responsibility or you
have a role to play in learning how to
how to deal with this or navigate this
um it's it's far more convenient to say
I have trauma or I have this diagnosis
or that diagnosis or the other and it
doesn't always lead to um changing a
relationship sometimes it leads to it
becoming a bit of a crutch or it
becoming your defining characteristic
you know um like what my whole
personality is having ADHD well that's
not is there nothing else interesting
about you um is is that it so yeah
there's there's a
a few different things there what do you
mean when you talk about therapy culture
is that a culture of people getting
therapy no um it's it's a sort of it
seems to be this overarching thing
that's enveloped society and even you
know down to the way we speak so um
therapy culture is
this you you you hear friends they you
know will have a small disagreement and
then they start having this whole whole
struggle session like a therapy session
and you know like you triggered my inner
child and when you didn't show up to
this thing or people setting boundaries
with with each other but they're not
really setting boundaries they're sort
of um making demands on other people or
um you know it's it's the way people
speak has shifted and changed um instead
of necessarily developing any real
understanding of mental health um we've
developed this sort of codification of
fragility um that's
that's I guess become its own its own
language um you know I'm triggered uh
when often they mean I'm offended um and
it's the whole you know I guess pop
psychology insta therapy stuff beginning
to dominate the mainstream understanding
of mental health so yeah what's so talk
to me about the difference you've used
that a couple of times today pop
psychology uh what's the difference
between that and mental health and and
why is it an issue that it's
masquerading is it because it's it's
it's not related to psychology or
Psychotherapy often um but speaking of
psychotherapy something you just said
was um suggest maybe you're a natural
psychotherapist when you're talking
about how I don't know what sad means to
you and that's something again in in
itic therapy that that you would do so
if you said I feel sad well I would ask
you what that means to you you take
anything that's abstract and you make it
a specific as possible but um yeah bit
of an aside um the difference is
that actual mental health is rarely
spoken about in any real way apart from
maybe anxiety and depression and you
know when they talk about mental health
awareness it's almost always it's like
Instagram therapists have become modern
day clergy or something or like pastoral
counselors telling people how to behave
so um giving people's scripts for life
um watering down important Concepts like
trauma and
PTSD um lowering the bar like you said
for you know like no being someone
pinching your bum is not nice if it's
unwanted but it's not the same as
actually being assaulted and conflating
the two things is absurd um so it's it's
all of those things kind of creating
this this blanket around people this
coddling blanket that
um ensures that you you you won't
necessarily be res I'm sort of really
rambling and I think of like you know
when you start sentencing you're like I
really hope I find my way I hope I can
land the plane you're you're making
sense to me I've got I've got some of
one of my favorite posts from you some
ways pop psychology lies to you everyone
you dislike is not a narcissist every
unpleasant experience is not trauma
having needs does not make you
codependent disagreement is not
gaslighting conflict is not abuse taking
offense is not being triggered
everything does not need to be
normalized and speaking like an HR memo
is not self-awareness are these sort of
the whatever it is nine Horsemen of pop
psychology are these sort of the most
common culprits these are these are
definitely some of them so so yeah thank
you for bringing that up because that um
uh helps and um it's it's stuff like the
the the dialogue around narcissism um
it's creating this strange you know
fanfiction version of narcissism that
only lives on the internet um
and anybody you don't like is a
narcissist any form of abuse or or poor
treatment is narcissism um again you
know words mean things especially when
there it's clinical language um and and
we've taken this you know therapy speak
which is a part of therapy culture and
you use it to inflate every little thing
so yeah you know you're not just
offended or you don't like something or
you're uncomfortable you've been
triggered when triggered means the
involuntary you know immersion into a
past traumatic experience you haven't
been triggered you don't like this or
it's caused cognitive dissonance
um anything difficult is trauma it can't
be pain it can't be bad luck it can't
there can be it's a foro conclusion
there's no there's it just closes the
door on any any other possibilities any
any expl any explanation um that might
not be this very convenient um bow to
wrap around your experience disagreement
is gaslighting any conflict is abuse
yeah you know and so someone disagreeing
with you what a convenient way to shut
down the conversation demonize them make
yourself the victim and and not have to
self-reflect just call them just say
they're gaslighting you you don't have
to learn how to how to um argue properly
or defend your ideas you can just say
everyone's a gaslighter how convenient
um and this kind of like I get policed a
lot on how I speak because I'm quite
straightforward and I just I resent um
having to put tons of fluff around my
words
because you know someone can't handle
just being spoken to like an adult and I
don't I'm not going to do it um and I
guess this is what they call Tone
policing so I get a lot of a lot of um
comments and DMS with from people saying
you know your message is good but the
way you come across is really harsh and
I just think
it really isn't if you try and read it
neutrally it's just stating a simple
fact or opinion most of the time and if
you heard me say it in my tone to your
face um I don't think you take it the
same the same way and um there's this
sort of I think a tone people bring to
things um and again it's it's the so I
similar to what I wrote in that post I I
see a lot of that just in in some of the
responses I get um even in this last
week I've had just this steady stream of
abuse to do with um anything I've said
about Israel and Palestine and mostly my
position has been um don't bomb children
like I don't uh you know I don't I don't
know what's I'm not I'm not arrogant
enough to pretend I know what the answer
to the solution is and I think anybody
who thinks it's simple is a idiot you
know just very very stupid because
you know it goes back a very long time
there's so many factors to consider here
anyway um and I so I don't know what the
right answer is but I do know that you
don't just indiscriminately kill
children just don't um and people read
things that you that you haven't written
and they attack you for them so you know
like you're you're a Jew hater or you're
um islamophobic or you're not taking
enough of a St
or um something else but then the other
thing they do is they begin to use this
therapy language to analyze you uh and
then you get that in some of the DMs I
think your insert some diagnosis or your
your gaslighting everybody or your um
and you know it's it's um
again it's weaponizing this language and
I think that's that's one of my big
problems with it is that it gets used as
a a cudel against people um yeah so
weaponizing this language Li you know
inhibiting any sort of actual
self-reflection um finding a way to
always land in the victim position
abdicate responsibility is there any
argument to be made that this normalizes
the conversation around mental health
which overall is a net benefit we've got
people maybe misappropriating language
using it inaccurately imprecisely uh but
this is a conversation now where people
are opening up about the way that they
they're in a experience feels uh this is
a a move in the right direction what's
your how do the scales balance in your
world it's really difficult actually
because on
on because I often don't think we are
even talking about mental health when we
say we're talking about mental health
but I think you're right I think it's
it's it's good good that
um there's a more receptive atmosphere
to people being able to say actually my
mental health suffering at the moment
and and there's a decent chunk of people
who won't turn away or turn against you
who'll be understanding and Incredibly
empathetic and um that probably is
incredibly different to you know our
parents generation for example and I
think yeah that is a net positive that's
that's really good what would
a what would an actual conversation
around mental health look
like I think an actual conversation
around mental health would look like
discussing actual mental health issues
what it what it's like to suffer from
them
identifying um you know some of the
signs that maybe this isn't normal
distress or normal hard time there's
something a bit deeper going on um
helping people you
know learn how to manage their mental
health um similar to how a diabetic has
to watch their sugar intake and take
insulin when you have an ongoing mental
health issue you you need to you need to
manage it you you know right I i' I've
kind of got it in my head that there's
this um it's kind of like a globalwide
concept creep or an Overton window uh of
what we've considered uh within the
realm of the conversation about mental
health yeah as we've identified you know
by DSM criteria many people who say or
use particular
sort of pathological language to
identify whatever it is that they got
going on might not meet the criteria if
they were to be assessed using that but
they've got something going on right
they are sad or they are depressed or
they are down or they feel anxious or
they whatever or they they feel
depressed like they are not depressed
right yeah um
so I think that yeah maybe you could say
um using the uh sort of psychoanalytic
uh treatment style language is is not
really helping and it's pathologizing
and it's causing issues but all that you
do really there is Kick the Can down the
road right that okay so we're not going
to use that language anymore but we
still now need a huge new bucket within
which people who are feeling a little
bit sad people who who are feeling a
little bit agitated a little bit
frustrated they're a little bit wistful
they're a little bit whatever right
there now needs to be an entire new
bucket within which we put those people
and maybe it's not mental health maybe
mental health should be um held for a
different an entire different lexicon
entire different sort of world but the
people who aren't lying about it and
aren't completely making it up which is
a good chunk of
them the people who are genuinely
feeling something that isn't meeting the
medical criteria but is still doing
something that disrupts their quality of
life that group of people you know like
that's I would guess the the large group
of people but if that's not mental
health we now need to we need to think
about it I think what's happened is it's
become conflated right like the acute
acute but mild distress has been moved
into this much more sort of
aggressive medical language but we still
need to treat those people and we still
need to have a conversation around
whatever those feelings are and whatever
the name is that we give those things
that they're feeling why can't we just
say sadness or wistfulness or loneliness
or why does it need a whole new set of
of words that's that again it's the you
know it's The Human Experience and I
think this is one of the things that
we've lost along the way with the whole
like follow your bliss and people
thinking Hollywood films are what life
is going to be like life is [__]
difficult um you know your your feelings
sometimes are incredibly hard to manage
um things happen all the time you know
you never know what's around the corner
um life is incredibly un unpredictable
and I think there's this idea that that
it it should be easy in some way or that
you you know if you're not happy all
blissfully happy all the time that
there's something wrong and there isn't
who unless you're a complete blithering
idiot who's happy all the time like I
don't know anyone everyone has you know
um ups and downs and and differences and
changes in mood and um their own
personal difficulties and I think maybe
you know using a word that I've come to
loath maybe that's what we need to
normalize is that this is what being a
person is um and you know you you have
to find you can't change that what you
can change is making yourself stronger
and more resilient and to know how to
respond when these things happen you
might not be able to control um bouts of
of sadness or wistfulness or agitation
but you can learn that when you're in a
hole to stop digging you can learn that
you can learn how to how to climb out um
you can learn how to avoid that hole
sometimes um where do you go to if let's
say that you're going through a bit of a
tough time yourself uh for whatever
reason where do you go to in your mind
what are the things that you rely on you
know it seems like people are relying on
labels and and and medical language what
about you given that you're a a
practitioner of this and have been at
the front lines for a decade what are
the things that you rely on to help
improve your mood or to give you some
perspective when you're kind of caught
in the whirpool that is the minations of
the human
mind
um
so I I okay so I've I've had a kind of
eventful life and been through some
really really tough stuff
um becoming basically homeless um
assault just you know I won't go into
all of it but difficult things so
sometimes there are things that
I think would be really difficult for
some of you didn't have those
experiences that don't always even
register with me um because I guess that
threshold has been expanded to the point
where it's it's it's it's different and
I'm sure other people who've got that
kind of History can can relate but then
I also I think because I've had that and
I've been in the complete depth like
drowning um and had to had to find a way
the hard way to deal with those emotions
that I'm not scared of them and not only
am I not scared of them um not scared of
other people's either so if something
happens like anxiety which sometimes you
know anxiety feelings of depression I
lost my mom two years ago so it's been a
lot of grief um even rage jealousy all
the feelings that people
feel I let myself feel them I let them
exist I don't necessarily even have to
you know you don't necessarily even have
to participate you know you just have
you just let them be let them exist let
them run their course um not not panic
about it not necessarily think that it's
a problem to solve it's like there's a
feeling um if you're so inclined you
could figure out and with practice you
can get very good at this figure out
where what caused it where is it coming
from oh I had that thought oh [__]
that's what that's what just deflated my
mood or um that lady I ran into in the
supermarket today she reminded me of the
way my mom belittled me and that's why
I've been so sad and anxious ever since
so you can trace it back you can figure
you can figure that out um and also just
just knowing that like you've survived
every single tough thing bad day bad
mood up to this point you're going to
survive this one too why is this any
different um and the thing about not
being scared of it
is like anxiety can be incredibly
frightening and I've been through the
the um you know been through been
through the experience of being very
frightened by Panic and thinking you
know something something really awful
was going to happen and then my dad
taught me this because he struggles with
some anxiety too and he said when when
the anx I think I remember 17 or 18 and
a panic attack and my dad said just the
anxiety can't do anything to you um and
when it comes
up look it right in the eye and tell it
do your worst you can't do anything to
me and I think that's kind of my
attitude to to love a lot of things that
seems based on what I know about you
that seems on brand yeah um but it it
can help and knowing that knowing that
that um metacognition watching your
thoughts thinking about your thoughts
knowing that right now I'm panicking and
I think I'm going to have a heart attack
and die but I know that's the anxiety
and the Panic it's not going to happen
and I said wait this out WIP up a l if
you have to um and then the other thing
is
with anxiety and panic especially um
move metabolize that chemistry like burn
it off quicker just run down the street
like a crazy person it'll it'll go away
um and yeah and so so it does depend but
you also have to develop some form of
mental health hygiene around it um just
made a course for i' I have this little
online community and I make courses for
them just made a course on Mental Health
hygiene and and
you know how to actually look after your
mental health and the factors that
contribute to you being well where
should people go if they want to check
that out um there's a link in my bio on
Instagram and on Twitter or you can
connect to it through my website um
what's the website it's my name.com
cava.com fantastic and um and you know
for for looking after yourself and for
for feeling well you need certain things
and they're
non-negotiable um like purpose if you
don't have a reason to wake up in the
morning of course you're going to become
depressed and anxious if you don't go
outside ever um which I struggle with
sometimes the work from home and
sometimes they ABS you can get
everything delivered um so you know you
have to force yourself you have to have
meaningful social interactions internet
doesn't count um you know social media
has made us so connected and yet so
isolated from actual real
human beings um you need to you know we
evolved in nature we didn't evolve in
these in these concrete boxes um you
have to you know once in a while go and
look at a tree for God's
sakes if you live in the city or
whatever but there's certain things you
need um and the way that our environment
is now of course everybody is struggling
with something and it's not only the
codling and the you know safety culture
and whatever else it's it's you're stuck
on on devices you're looking at social
media which is you know we know that's
um a threat to mental health we know
that it's it's a contributing factor to
depression and anxiety we know the
impact that it has on young people and
teenagers sometimes to a really tragic
um conclusion and then you're indoors
all day and your sedentary which is
going to make you incredibly depressed
if you're not moving where we weren't
designed to just sit on our Bombs all
day we were designed to move um and
found that like I've gotten really into
working out since last December and um
it's gotten to the point now
where it it you know so I finish work
and as soon as I finish I just get on
the treadmill and sometimes I finish
quite late so I just that's just my my
transition and
um it's almost even if I'm tired even if
I don't want to do it as soon as I start
it's that feeling of like you know when
you sink into a warm bath and it's that
that kind of whole body like like oh
that's better that's the feeling and you
know there's I'm sure a really good
reason for that for why it feels that
good for why you you know
um there's there's so much that we need
to be well that isn't um part a natural
part of our environment anymore even
even staying up late and looking it the
blue light in our phones and there's so
much that actively contributes to us
being disconnected
sedentary eating food that that doesn't
give us the nutrition that we actually
need the synthesize some of those you
know some of that
neurochemistry um you're dealing with
this onslaught of the most horrific
devastating things happening all around
the world all the time which we're not
wired to handle you know we can't cope
with that like before you know we I
think the the figure is something
like you would only know the bad news of
your area and only maximum in your whole
life know about 150 people um in the
kind of radius of the The Village or
town or wherever you live and you know
to hear the bad news from this happened
to the neighbor this happened to the
next town and that's kind of it now
we're hearing everything that happens
everywhere all the time at the same time
and you and you can't you can't cope
with it um yeah given that there's so
much there that you've gone through
which is you know outside of the
um the way that we move the things that
we eat the amount of sunlight we're
exposed to the friends that we have the
purpose that we uh use to propel us
through life why do you think we've
spent so much time obsessing about the
self and our emotions in the west
because life's too easy um you know like
where nobody human beings aren't wired
to just sit back on their Laurels and
enjoy the [__] Sunshine like that's
not what we were wired to do we're wired
to to overcome obstacles and challenges
and keep moving forward in some way and
when when you remove all the challenges
and make life too comfortable it's like
people starting malfunctioning and you
know when there's
there's and I think there there'll be a
lot of people who'll absolutely bulk at
this and say how dare you say life is
easy in the west and then I I just think
go and live somewhere else for a little
bit and and then you'll understand how
good you actually have it like from
every little thing like um you know
you're not going to have a power cut
every day you can rely on the
electricity um all the sort of Public
Services you might find them too Bure
bureaucratic or annoying but they work
like Swiss watch compared to some of the
other places in the world um you're
relatively safe you've got free
education and free healthcare in this
country you know like the dogs in this
country that have better lives than
people in other places and um and when
there's no nothing external to to
necessarily struggle against and then
you have had these you know coddling
helicopter overprotective parents
removing any obstacle from your path
what's that phrase you know prepared the
the the child for the road not the road
for the child
um
and and you end up with um sorry I
looked away for a second and I
completely lost my train of thought well
I've got something I've got I've got
what I like something really interesting
just came there which is it seems like
victimhood culture has arisen because
the human systems demand for challenges
yeah in life has outstripped the modern
world's ability to supply them yeah I
think that's one factor and that really
well said but I think the other factor
is also that because things have been so
good people have an unrealistic idea of
what life should be like so there should
never be anything difficult no one
should ever be offended you should be
protected from your feelings ever being
hurt um and this sort of very
unrealistic Camelot like idea for how a
person should feel you should you
know you see some of some of these posts
on Instagram like you deserve this and
you are worthy and and I don't know
about you but I didn't get that
messaging as a kid and I'm really
grateful um and the messaging I got was
yeah you can do anything you want but
get off your butt and earn it um and
then you know
I'm glad and if you're good enough it
wasn't you deserve it because you you
think you do who are you none of us none
of us um go through your schooling
system and uni if you go to UNI then
you're just going to meet someone your
soulmate fall in love um then you're
going to find your perfect career which
is going to be rewarding and pay you
what you want and you know then you
somehow magically have a really nice
house in a car and kids if you want them
and then they actually you know reach
adulthood and they're in for such a rude
shock because um it doesn't necessarily
go that way um instead you kind of you
struggle and you realize no there's no
dream job and soulmate that's going to
fall in your lap um there's you know you
have to make things happen you have to
take responsibility and you know
combined with this self-esteem parenting
that tells children constantly how
special they are how clever they are how
talented they are and then they grow up
and find out that the world doesn't
reflect that back to them because maybe
they aren't that talented and amazing um
and become incredibly depressed
and
nihilistic what do you think it seems
like selfworth or the interpretation of
our own selfworth is kind of an
important element here what do you think
people get wrong about self-worth and
where it comes from I think what they
get wrong about it is that self-worth
does not come from other people
inflating you or you know blowing smoke
up your ass that doesn't do anything
that doesn't like that doesn't hit the
core of you it's it's this whole like
validation you know how it's so
important you have you invalidated me
like so [__] what like you're an
adult um and I think it doesn't it
doesn't touch the sides and the thing it
does is make people constantly dependent
on more from from those around them
which is why it's so crucial to have
everybody validate your feelings and
your Viewpoint and tell you how
wonderful you are but actual selfworth
is hard one and it's earned through
surviving things and um you know set
setting a challenge for yourself and
actually accomplishing it um keeping
your word to yourself do you know how
[__] difficult that is and how few
people can do it um and I I struggle
with it all the time it's a constant
battle but don't stop ever trying um
keeping your word to yourself will
change your relationship with your sense
of of selfworth develop competence in
something you know um have a purpose
that makes you excited to be alive all
those things will not only take your
focus off you know this idea that having
self-esteem selfworth and you know warm
and fuzzy feelings inside is you know
the be all and end all of life but
it'll give you that grounded sense of
self assur self assuredness assess I
don't know um that that changes how you
feel in the world I think you've just
described probably the large the big
changes that I made over the last decade
yeah you know yeah absolutely keeping my
word to myself uh being able to build up
trust that if I said I was going to do a
thing that I was going to do a thing um
creating a competency in something that
I genuinely felt proud of myself myself
about uh having a purpose that gave me a
reason to get up in the morning you know
the these have been the big movers for
me um and you know that's wrapped in
better sleep and wake and more of a
focus on like holistic health and
fitness and not just looking jacked and
having people around me that seem to
care about me and integrating not just
on the internet and all the rest of
those things right but like the big
movers the big movers largely have been
my scent of self which was born out of
making promises to myself and keeping
them and
I remember the first episode that I did
with Jordan Peterson three years ago now
maybe more um was he's got this little
line people can go back and listen to it
and he just like throws it away toward
the end of the episode and he says if
you want a true adventure in life if if
you want an exciting Adventure in life
tell the truth like tell the truth and
see how big of an adventure that is he's
like boy that's an adventure and it's
true like if if you want to one of the
most difficult scary terrifying things
to do is to regularly just keep telling
the truth over and over again to not
people please uh to not be bitter or
resentful
posture to uh try and inflate what it is
that you've achieved or downplay it to
just say what it is which is really the
path of least resistance because you
don't need to create this big [__]
Mirage of of stuff that's All Hiding
what's actually going on uh and yet for
some reason that seems to be
just is very very difficult to do it's
very difficult yeah and telling the
truth to yourself I think that can't be
stated enough because the ways in which
we pull the wool over our own eyes is um
brilliant but you
know there's I completely agree and like
the truth is one of my you know like
it's it's a really important value to me
um and a lot of people really hate Sam
Harris but I I I like him for this is
because he doesn't try to Pander to any
tribe especially the sort of like a woke
and anti-woke binary and he just says
what he actually thinks and feels about
things so everybody seems to hate him
but he's he's um I'm sure his mind is
organized in a in a different way um in
I I agree I mean I had him on the show
got a lot of stick for having him on the
show 3 months ago and it was Sam
Harris's World embarrassment tour people
were commenting and I thought to myself
like I I had so much fun I did three and
a half hours with him and I had so much
fun sat down opposite and talking and I
understand that people don't like him
because of his view on this or you know
this just shows that you're not going to
hold someone's feet to the fire about
this that or the other I was like dude
there are people out there that I know
for a fine fact are way less trustworthy
but just said the right things they made
the right mouth noises at the time when
you wanted to about the issue that you
care about and you would much sooner
have a lying but complicit Ally as
opposed to a honest but antagonistic
adversary and for me like I'm not saying
that I'm going to like I don't agree
with tons of the stuff that Sam said but
I [__] believe that he believes it
and the fact that I believe that he
believes it gives me a lot of faith that
in the future when he says a thing that
I can believe it too and given the fact
that truth and being able to actually
have faith in someone's word is really
important and maybe there's stuff that
he said that contradicts I'm sure that
there is all the rest of it caveat
caveat caveat for the internet but yeah
like I I believe that he believes the
things that he says and I don't I don't
think that that can be said for an awful
lot of people so that was why I was
super excited to sit down with him uh
and I will do it again and you know like
[__] the internet for like I I I had I
had so much fun talking to him I thought
it was really really interesting I
learned a lot and you know if if if if
people have got an issue with the way
that he comes across with things then
you know I guess he's not for you
anymore and the felt sense one of the
things I've reflected on this a lot one
of the things I think people have an
issue with is they thought Sam was their
guy and Sam was their guy for a little
while yeah and now Sam feels like he's
not their guy and one of the big
emotions that seems to be driving this
is kind of like a betrayal you know yeah
yeah um it's like group thing tribalism
thing and
people try and pretend they're above it
none of us are really you kind of have
to mitigate your
impulses and I think I think that's what
it is like these very tribal groups
online that dominate you know discourse
of everything
um that they're far more punishing of
Heretics and dissident than they are of
like actual adversaries I think um if
you if you change your mind mind and you
you speak out against the group and you
absolutely should um you absolutely
should you shouldn't you shouldn't
because there's a real price it it's not
nice and i' I've had a lot of it like I
said this last week a lot of attacks and
um losing followers and all that like
fun stuff but but I I think there's a
bigger price to pay to just assimilate
with the group
and and sacrifice what do you actually
think go against your conscience and not
tell the truth um which is why I respect
Sam Harris I don't agree with anything
or not with everything he says I don't
agree with everything anyone says um but
what I can respect about him is that he
seems to have integrity he has the
courage to tell the truth as best as he
can see it um and he tries to think
things through um and I you know like
you said I don't think there's that many
people like that out there instead you
have this like Legion of parrots with
huge platforms that just you
know all say the same thing um worded
slightly differently um or they say
things that you know on purpose to
inflame um you know inflame their own
audience against another group of people
I mean this is this is like my rule of
whether a Creator is or is not acting in
good faith is is Their audience mostly
bound together over the mutual hatred of
an outg group or the mutual of an in
group that's one of the easiest rubrics
to use okay like do they do they bond
together by identifying the other and
then saying we are not that or is it
this is a community of people because
shared hatreds are much more powerful
than shared loves right way more
powerful wartime [__] patriotism
versus peacetime patriotism you kidding
me um but one of your other posts that I
really loved was uh sometimes we are the
top toxic ones and no one wants to admit
that no one wants to actually point the
finger at themselves you know whether
it's fundamental attribution error or
you know whatever type of motivated
reasoning to wiggle your way out of
being culpable for the things like
everybody is a prick lots of the time
right yeah me me included and you know
just accepting the fact that we can be
like that and and to kind of round out
that Sam thing I've been feeling it a
bit recently uh we're deep into the
episode now which means that all of the
people who don't actually usually listen
to this aren't listening anymore so I
can I can talk more
openly I've been feeling it a bit
recently because the Channel's grown so
much it's like tripled this year I think
maybe more by the end of this year it'll
have more than tripled uh and and an
awful lot of like increasing levels of
scrutiny and then you kind of
become you become a thing you're no
longer a person you're a representation
of ideas and there's expectations and
there's um um not judgment but there's a
a a rhythm to how people expect you to
show up and you're kind of put into this
particular box you like Chris used to be
X or Chris is a part of Y uh and I feel
in myself these Dynamics moving below
the surface and this kind of engine
begin to tune up which is precisely the
one that Sam is kind of feeling the
other side of at the moment which is
like we thought that you were on our
side with X or Y or Zed and if you seem
to be an unreliable Ally if you seem to
do something that goes against what the
main group was supposed to do I made
some I had an interesting conversation
with Constantin kiss and I know you've
been on trigonometry I had this
conversation with him about how um
people on the right say you shouldn't
judge people by one interaction but you
know Bud Light had had a pretty stellar
career of making like watery beer for
Americans and then they did the dill
milany thing and now the entire company
was thrown under the bus and I was like
that's I it's just a thought experiment
like it's an interesting should this
maybe you know maybe it could be a
different perspective and we could think
about it in this kind of a way but
people are so incapable of seeing any
idea or any uh any discussion as
anything shy of a hill that someone's
prepared to die on that they immediately
come back with that same sort of energy
and I'm like whoa whoa whoa this is this
channel is evidently not for [__] you
right if I can't play about with ideas
on here uh but again you know I see this
Dynamic the one that we're talking about
with Sam and and maybe the one that he
is on the other end of where you go well
it's way easier for me to just not play
about with those ideas anymore you know
this month like 20 million people have
seen the channel and it's way easier for
me to not ever say to just feed red meat
to the Mob to not say anything that's
like interesting or adventurous or
playing around with ideas or exploratory
because I know that if I do do that and
I'm imprecise or I'm off that day or
it's just a [__] [__] idea which I
have all the time like I know that
ultimately that's going to come back to
bite me in the ass so why should I do
that and again like that Dynamic is one
of the reasons why I think the people
that are deciding like yeah I'm going to
even if it's unpopular even if it's and
the same goes for you you know like you
could continue to sort of
spout cotton candy for the Soul at
people but to say something which
is going to get you as many haters as it
do does lovers is a more difficult path
yeah I I I love it I I really appreciate
your your
contrarian uh slightly uh prickly but
very very honest uh approach to all of
this stuff I think that it's a very
important redress to the sort of cod
psychology stuff that we do see on the
internet and it validates people in a
much more honest way like it is still
validation it's just not the kind of
sort of cotton candy for the soul
validation that everyone's looking for
so let's say that someone's loved what
they've heard today where should they go
to find out more of the posts that
you've got and everything else that you
do um you can find me on Instagram and
on Twitter and my handle in both places
is my full name c k Chava um my website
is the same my name.com and that links
to this online community that I run with
courses and so on if that interests
people um so yeah that's where you can
find me online don't try and find me in
person
please hell yeah I really appreciate you
thank you thank you so much if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe